there's some bad news about bananas have
you heard about this true story a strain
of banana destroying fungus has been
wiping out banana crops in Asia you've
heard about this right and yeah
scientists are worried that soon the
fungus could spread around the world and
make bananas go extinct this is a real
news story yes and they're worried about
it soon now they're not saying this is
definitely happen but soon if a fungus
spreads there could be no more bananas
okay sorry to bring that up but I don't
want you to worry I want to assure you
right now bananas are not going to go
extinct we here at Conan would never let
that happen that's why a great personal
expense I'm paying for this I have set
up a banana habitat in the building
where we have a captive breeding pair of
bananas
their names are Sasha and Kiko and
lately they've been giving signs that
they're going to mate very soon let's
take a look at their enclosure on this
closed-circuit feed there is Sasha and
Kiko looks like they're they're just
resting you're just resting well that's
pretty typical banana behavior yeah
they're just resting we'll check back in
with them later and I'm optimistic they
will mate soon I really am and then we
don't have to worry about this fungus at
all what's just I'm just just sick a
second let's just check back in quickly
with the breeding pair of bananas
looks like Sasha and Kiko still resting
let's give them a little more time yeah
we'll give them a little more time see
folks you can't rush this kind of thing
the banana not a bold fruit a rather shy
fruit but I I personally hope that
eventually they will mate they'll create
more bananas and then we do not have to
worry about it let's go check back see
if they're okay yeah let's check in with
Sasha and Kiko just one more time see
what's going on okay they're still there
[Applause]
yeah
[Applause]
III I didn't think they would go at it
like yeah yeah I mean they went from
zero yes to like a hundred in just a
second once again typical banana behave
really yeah why sarau sleep later can
tell which one is the male yeah is when
they're all right I'm guessing by now
just going by my own personal biological
clock I'm guessing they're done
let's check in if they've calmed down
let's jump in right now
[Applause]
no please stop it go away let's not
stone when the peel comes off I get very
upset I I'm sorry I know I don't think
what we're not gonna look at it we're
not gonna look at that it might even
suppose they're playing to the camera
yeah I know they might be getting off on
it I don't know but I know that we don't
check in on that again well I don't know
I mean they had the peels halfway off
let's see if they get the peels all the
way up do you guys
[Applause]
[Applause]
I think there's a oh my god that's
enough let's eat enough I didn't think
that Wow there was a pair just like
watching you see the pair is a creep
hair is doing nothing a selfish creepy
pair and that's my take on the banana
story
[Applause]
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]